中学交互なって済みの宿題を終わらせたことがありません
和美社長です子供たちは外の全体的の宿題どうですか
8月の半ばなんでそうそうなって休んで折り返しなんですけども今終わってないやつ
そのままだとまめぞ僕も経験してるんですけども夏休みの宿題は本当にうぜそのそう
だって夏休み
休みなんてお休みなので宿題夏ってことはそれ休みじゃないじゃないですか
矛盾となぜになってず見てその8人が名目上だけだってなんで宿題とか坂上体操とか
部活とか再ブームでやら戦でそれぞれセミがありませんだって話僕はずっとそれがボケ
なんですよ
デビューでやはりこの
社会というものはそういうのを許してくれないようになっていますので結局皆さん休み
なんですけどもし来ない辺境先月目ですよねまぁ俺はやったことないけどね
僕は高校づらいがまともに宿題を出したことがありません黒板に未提出者の卵みたいな
ところにずっと僕の酒だとか名前が張っちゃったくらい本当に近いをやらない奴でした
逆にしないとか全然出さないのになんか全国ボスとかで校内1位とかになっ
止めのドヤ顔た部屋
束ランズとりわけだな梱包でいいの僕が少ないいらない派の人間なんですけどまぁそれ
でもやんなきゃいけないとはたくさんいる
特に小学生とか嫌でしょというわけでまずいう研究とかいろいろあると思うんですけど
も俺の記憶が正しければみんなねこういうなってやってるの取れるって
奪われてると思うんですよというわけで今回ここ最近勉強と昨夜の所もないこのおじ
さん
完全に脳内のポッパーハッピーの状態で夏休みのドリルを
中がをとって3年生にしたんですけどまぁ小学生がわたさベルである夏休みの宿題を
どれだけかよ終わらせられるのか今回検証してみようと思いますちょうど校の皆
ぜひ参考にしてねもうそれがこれ10分とかで終わらせることができたら小学生の
みんなは
まだシクがやらなくていいかもしれないでも俺ねすごい時間かかったらみんなすぐ
少ないやろうね結構馬鹿だと思うんですけどそれでも頑張って言ってみると思います
とりあえず全部を合わせればクリアということでこれ国語と算数だけなんでうっ今日
からやるとたぶんこれが終わってタイムの3倍ぐらいかかるかなと思っていただいて
結構だと思いますじゃあ3僕は今がの小学生なんでたまにね
お供に
時間遊びに来るかもしれないんですけど全然なんで友達が遊びに来る時間なども考慮し
てのタイムになると思います
4位佐藤ん
[音楽]
松井裕にロールないぞ
チャイぐらいロジャーズは本気でまずは全部忘れたんです
掛け算の千葉に0-3家 the 7終え待っててくれ
米若菜終わったらいいですね
voodoo
小学校めんどくさいなんかめっちゃ細かい計算をガッカリさせられるけど
ません
5 a day
あー入賞館本日は5名も僕宿題やってるの宿題なんてやらない過疎もうらめない怒られ
ちゃう言えボス試しに1週間くらい遅れても先生は何も言ってない
だめだよ貴方てスゴポルもうぴょん
じゃわかったわかったわかったわわかったわかったねわかった待っては神は紹介を待っ
てはカラーにじゃあここまでやったら祖母
ここまでやったら
分かったそこ頑張れに言うんですっ
8日
vector
外して小皿染まるシェアなぁほらん
渡辺位
ありがとうまたあとイージーねーよ帰りますよねタイムロスで0
スチール5倍
ぬんぬバイ
保険
[音楽]
逆に
技マ
マジで舐め美味いじゃんこれはどんなギャルの8倍終わったらなぜて回った
[音楽]
泊まりたいまたはいただきません
た自分だ
[音楽]
はい
を
医学ん
4分浅野しまいます8月妻待ってください
夜泣きも連れてきたんだけどこだってごめんなさい教団天井もよろしくないがまだ
終わってないの
そうかまた笹にくれよじゃ
なません
[音楽]
くれればっ
あずっ
gantz やってるじゃんガチャ1回で k
だけど ok だけだろじゃなければ仕方ないなぁ
わあああ楽しかったーーー
まずないんだ時間だなぁ
もう始めないしてるんだよお兄ちゃんお兄ちゃん宿題が終わらないんだよ
そんな魂胆だろんじゃって手伝って写ってるほぼ手伝ってほぼ水膨張願い
何がしていあっ
[音楽]
お兄突っ張り月お姉ちゃん我帰らん
てお兄ちゃんそっかね兄ちゃんも座へどうぞ
[音楽]
えええ1学期のまとめだやっと3500
うわぁなんで学力診断テストってやまとめなおに過去の家だぜたる難敵ずれるとわー
ua
ん
[音楽]
が終わった中
grow 次は国語で僕は国交が苦手なので全部う2させていただけます
まあ
[拍手]
絶対れなくても皆うん大丈夫だよを見てっちゃなんだけど
うんもうが持ってきたからまあこれ食ってから
しくねがんばれ分かった夜ご飯大事だもんですつかれていうかなん
いただきまーさー
それのをなもんですなっ
[音楽]
よろしくグループ戦たんですか
をガーン
vector
できたのできたーーーーをガンガンやったか動画で見て
[音楽]
までまずやってるんですか leader
me
はいはい本気で夏休みのドリル
やってみると1時間29分56秒1時間半かかってしまいました
ただに強化でこれだったんで社会と理科と英語が入ってくると
4時間5時間ぐらい見といたほうがいいかますねなぜでも1日で終わりましたいって
こと
ただ行っててマジで on
おったなぁがペグバリバリ答えも写った中華まったりと
悪い悪い答えも写しお兄ちゃんに協力してもらったりいろいろ本当に全力を尽くして
多分この時間だったんで
小学校のみんなはドリル終わるときはごぢたん見といた方がいいと思いますあとね算数
がねマジで何か物を壊したくなるからイライラしてきまして本当にねあのー
5時間が終わるということを証明できたんですけどベクちゃんと攻めた方が良いと思い
ました
それがこの皆
ちゃんと勉強するんだぞ
[音楽]
me
バッハ